do it every day
the building blocks of the economy are
crumbling
High material costs staff shortages and
weak demand are weighing on construction
companies
they are going Vast at their fastest
rate in a decade
and the scale of the downturn has taken
the owner of this Brick Lane Company by
surprise
I've got a family to look after which is
my priority but I also have other guys
working for me who rely on the work and
also have families mortgages yeah it's a
little bit of a worry how much of your
costs has gone up
a lot I know yeah a hell of a lie
actually I mean materials have gone up
between 10 and 50 uh obviously inflation
has gone up so the guys that are working
for me want extra money
um it can't carry on the way it's going
um I don't get I can't charge that much
more I can't keep up with inflation
small and medium-sized businesses are
the Bedrock of the economy but they are
less equipped to deal with sharply
Rising costs and falling consumer demand
small house builders like this one in
Preston fear they may be a Dying Breed
we employ a small to medium-sized
developers a lot of people within the
the construction industry and The Wider
economy we as a construction so we
employ about a million people so the
ripple effect of anything that happens
to our industry is quite significant
throughout the wider economy
they are collapsing at their fastest
rate in a decade
construction companies account for a
fifth of this
insolvencies in the sector are at their
highest level since 2012. with 2094
insolvencies in the first half of this
year
everything from Timber to Steel has shot
up in price and these extra costs
they're not easy to pass on to customers
who are grappling with similar issues of
their own and it's the construction
sector with its wafer thin margins
that's driving this increase a clear
sign is any that Britain is in recession
High inflation and a slowing economy
it's a toxic mix that is destroying
businesses and jobs leaving everyone
with less money to spend
a negative downward spiral with some
distance left to run
Sky News